when you European Parliament marks
International Holocaust Remembrance Day
we pay tribute to the memory of the
victims of the Holocaust and reaffirm
our unwavering commitment to counter
anti-Semitism racism and all other forms
of hate Europe
remembers I invite you first to to to
view a video depicting the horror of the
aitz berau camp
as seen from the eyes of one of its
survivors the first woman president of
this European Parliament Simon
[Music]
Veil
on the 13th of April
1944 16-year-old Simon her sister meline
and her mother Ivon were loaded onto
cattle
Wagons at the end of a horrendous
journey of 3 days they arrived in
[Music]
ashit the train halted in the middle of
the night
even before the doors were opened we
were assailed by the C sh shouting of
the SS guards and The Barking of dogs
then there were blinding search lights
the unloading ramp it all took on a very
surreal air we were torn away from the
horrors of our journey and thrown into
the midst of a
nightmare we'd reached the end of the
journey the aitz beer Canal
camp we walked with the other women the
ones who are in the good line to a
distant concrete building with just one
window where the capos were waiting for
us I remember that when some people
asked questions the capos pointed out
the window to the crematorium chimney
and the smoke escaping from it we didn't
understand we couldn't understand what
was happening a few dozen meters from us
was so unimaginable that our very Minds
were incapable of admitting
it one after the other we passed in
front of Deportes who tattooed us from
that moment
on each of us became a mere
number inscribed into our
flesh the atmosphere of the crematorium
the smoke and the stench of beer Canal I
will never
forget
[Music]
dear colleagues dear dignitaries dear
Irene shashar every year at the end of
January this Parliament marks the
anniversary of the liberation of the
Nazi concentration and extermination
camp of aitz berau in
1945 we remember the victims of the
Holocaust we remember the 6 million
Jewish people Romany people LGBT
communities and many others who were
stripped of their dignity because of
their religious Faith their ethnicity
race or disability
the path that led to aitz and the
Holocaust began Generations before with
scapegoating bullying and
dehumanization it began with ostracizing
those seen as different by blaming the
other the German Nazi regime
exterminated 17 million men women and
children and inflicted unimaginable
suffering and pain on Millions more
While others silence stood
complicit as one Survivor put it the
truly horrific thing was the absence of
horror of so many the comfort of
indifference meant too many closed their
eyes and turned
away I am proud that the European
Parliament is not a place of
indifference I am proud that this house
speaks up against Hol Holocaust deniers
against conspiracy myths against
disinformation and against violence that
deliberately targets and singles out
members of our
communities because despite Decades of
effort we have not yet done enough to
combat
discrimination dear
Irene we are honored to have you here in
the European Parliament for this solemn
ceremony of remembrance
the European Parliament understands its
responsibility in the video we heard
Simon veil's recollection of the horrors
of aitz with the number
78651 tattooed on the her skin she
survived the evil of concentration camps
and changed the face of modern
Europe although dear Irene none of us
can fathom the extent of the pain that
you suffered
and you being a hidden child during the
war with nothing but your beloved do lka
as your sole
companion we will listen to your story
we will take your lessons with us we
will
remember on Holocaust Remembrance Day we
recall the importance of sharing stories
like yours today and for generations to
follow of protecting our values the
story of Europe is one of ideals and of
values it is one of overcoming tragedy
of Building Bridges between people of
turning enemies into partners and
Friends of building From the
Ashes over the years our Union has
transformed the lives of millions we
tore down barriers and replaced them
with common values we achieved Freedom
guaranteed prosperity and provided
opportunity we must continue to remember
Europe's story to remember its Horrors
and to treasure its accomplishment in
overcoming them to understand where we
came from and why and to teach these
lessons to our children ladies and
gentlemen we remember I would now like
to invite you all to listen to Marcelo
nissman a composer and performer of the
donon he composed this piece especially
for today's Holocaust Remembrance Day
event in the European
[Applause]
[Music]
Parliament
for
[Music]
I
[Applause]
for
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
the
[Applause]
I now give the floor to Irene shashar
Holocaust Survivor for her address miss
shashar the floor is yours
thank
honorable president of the European
Parliament Roberta
metola honorable members of the European
Parliament honorable ambassadors and
permanent
Representatives honorable vice
presidents and members of the European
commission honorable president of the
European economic and social
committee honorable
religious
Representatives ladies and
gentlemen at this
International
Holocaust remembrance
ceremony I stand here today in front of
you to tell
you that Hitler did not
win the year is
the year is
1942 I am 5 years
old my mother father and I are living in
the waro ghetto we're
starving in my
innocence I hoped that it was all
temporary
I wanted to believe that someone would
say
abracadabra and I would be back in my
own rightful home comfortable and
secure surrounded by my family's
love but that was only a child's
dream moving to the
ghetto was only the beginning
of our
nightmare the seeds of genocide had
already been planted in
1939 with the poison of
Nazism invading
Poland when we were forcibly moved into
the ghetto
survival was the only thing that
mattered
the conditions in the ghetto were awful
I was cold I was
barefoot I was
hungry I was afraid to look into the
eyes of a
stranger my mother and I often went to
scavenge for
food while my father would stay in our
tiny apartment
on one of these outings as my mother was
holding me
tight I noticed a dirty raw potato that
have fallen off a foot
cart I picked it
up I gave it to my mother she cleaned it
with her
skirt she broke it in
half for me to
eat I ate it with the
light I still remember its
taste it was
delicious the second half of the
potato I expected my mother to eat
herself since she was just as hungry as
I
was but she waited
she waited until I finished savoring the
first
half and gave me the second
half I'm telling you this to show you
that Mother's love is
unconditional on another afternoon while
my mother and I were again searching the
streets for spare bits of food we heard
blood curdling screams coming in the
direction of our cramped
apartment my mother yanked my little arm
and took off running in the direction of
the
screams she dashed up the
stairs of our our building fighting her
way through a crowd of
people and once we were there on the
landing the crowd was even
thicker but through the open
door we could see a
body a body strolled on the kitchen
floor it was my
father in his Rabbit dress shirt and his
sches or
suspenders lying there bleeding from a
gash on the side of his
throat mother dragged me with her she
threw herself and me on top of his Lim
body and
screamed
sobbing
inconsolably I was
scared she kept an iron grip on me as we
huddled together as a family for one
last
time my
elbow had nowhere to go except into a
pool of my father's
blood we stayed there for what felt like
an
eternity finally somebody pulled me away
and took me out of the
room I remember then feeling
relieved but that would be the last
time I ever saw my
father shortly after that horrific day
mother and I set out to find some food
only on this day something felt
different she was carrying a large black
bag and she let me take my
doll my beloved
litka she seemed to be going somewhere
with a purpose
with urgency with a
plan
suddenly she pulled open a
sewer
cover and tossed me down the
sewer it was
dark it was dirty it was
wet it was it was
awful and all I could see all I could
feel was this stream of smelly water
splashing against
me I clutched my beloved
litka and waited for my mother to join
me my eyes slowly but surely adjusted to
the
darkness and I saw the grimy tunnel all
around me and the
Rats the rats there were lots lots lots
lots of rats rats they were jumping they
were jumping on my head on my face they
were in my hair and they were jumping on
my poor
lka my mother pushed me from behind to
move us through the foul
gutter not only Not only was it
soggy but there was a tremendous
stench we were
crossing the sewer for the entire ghetto
area of
wara 80 years later I can remember the
stench like it was
yesterday I clutched my travel companion
my beloved licha close to my chest I
told her to be strong but neither She
nor I were immune to the horrific
conditions in the
sewer she was more than my precious doll
she was my best
friend and even she was not safe in this
hell on
Earth
then as quickly as forcefully as it had
begun the pushing from
behind suddenly
stopped my mother
scrambled
upward somehow she found a great she
hoisted me
up and then came out of the sewer
herself to this
day I still
wonder how did she know how far we had
to go in order to emerge outside of the
Ghetto
Walls we were now on the Aryan side of
Warsaw where Jews were absolutely
forbidden to be
my mother a pretty woman was blonde and
blueeyed and could pass as a
n she had friends from earlier years who
were willing to employ her in their
homes even though this was
dangerous for
them now
in this situation she could provide food
for herself and for
me
however taking me along
require that I be hidden in
closets from that moment
on I
became what is
known a holocaust hidden child
I was given a party for my lka and for
myself and my mother came came by every
once in a while with food and a kiss and
to tell me how much she loved
me I spent hours and
hours in dark
closets talking to my lka
we conforted each
other we hugged each other she was my
Hiding Place
companion I asked her over and over
again what did I do
wrong why am I being
punished I felt guilty I felt guilty of
something but of
what I did not
know my mother told
me that if I
behaved if I would not call her if I
would not complain if I would not make
any noise all this would be would soon
be over and there we could go out to the
park to play a
again ladies and gentlemen consider for
a
moment what my mother was telling me was
that the end of the war
dependent depended on my being
good could I really be
responsible for ending the
war
after several years of hiding and
running running to new places to stay
one step ahead of the
Gestapo the war was finally
over I must have been very very very
good we search for surviving relatives
and eventually we made our way to
Paris my mother found a job in a
hotel but there was no place for me
there so she sent me to an
orphanage
manal in
Andre established by the commission
Central the
all the children there were French
orphans whose parents had been deported
to death
camps I was the only polish
child I was also the only child with a
mother so she
became everybody's
mother at the manoir I learned for the
first time to read and
write and I was then 9 years
old thank you
friends for having provided me with a
refuge at a crucial time in my
life there were so many many questions I
wanted to ask my
mother who was my
savior and who gave me life over and
over
again she died in the spring of
1948 before I was able to ask and I then
became a full orphan
prior though to her sudden heart
attack she had one last
plan she made
arrangements for her for
me to live with her favorite niece whose
family had found a new life in Lima
Peru faila topilsky and her husband M
had the
generosity to take me
in gave me love and allowed me to start
a new life in the safety of their
home together with their
children Marcel and
Sonia I am forever thankful and grateful
for their love and
generosity they helped me make the
person
I am
today and I try to show that I deserve
their caring by being of course the best
student or the best student I could be
later I earned a scholarship to
university in the United
States Peru provided me with an
environment in which I could evolve from
a hidden Refugee child to another less
with hopes and dreams for the future
thank you
Peru my mother's foresight even after
she was no longer with me is a beacon of
light that has stayed me with me
throughout my
life I went to New York to study and
eventually from there made Delia to
Israel Israel
became my
country I had the privilege to
contribute to the education of
generations of students at the Hebrew
University of
Jerusalem during the 40 years I taught
their Applied
Linguistics I was blessed with the
opportunity to have children and
grandchild
children and I did the very thing Hitler
tried so hard to
prevent but Hitler did not
[Applause]
win
allow me to present to you my
victory my son David and my daughter
Elana would the two of you please stand
[Applause]
up
my son David is a doctor in
2006 he was seriously injured while
serving in the
IDF when he joined a paratrooper unit
that was
attacked he overcame his
injuries and founded an emerging biotech
company that is in the process of
developing and in ative device to reduce
newborn
mortality by delaying or preventing
premature
births his wife Rim is an intensive care
nurse who treat seriously injured
patients of all Races and
religions she has been working nonstop
since October
7th they have three children 13-year-old
nvo gifted gifted in mathematics who
just celebrate his celebrated his bar
mitzvah at the Wailing Wall 10-year-old
om who is an artistic gymnast and
aspires to be an olyp Olympic medalist
and donon the 7-year-old who regularly
charms all of
us my daughter Elana is a senior social
worker and Trauma specialist in the
municipality of
shoham since the
unprovoked attack on Israel on October
7th she has been on the front line of
the war at home leading support groups
to help the community deal with the
trauma of the
war helping families of hostages who
have been released back home and helping
those that are still waiting for their
loved ones to come
back Elana's husband
Assaf is an expert on Law and
Psychiatry he immediately volunteered to
join his res reserve unit on October
7th they share four children
four yarden age 20 is doing his military
service as are almost all 20 year olds
in
Israel he's a soldier in an elite unit
and we pray every day we pray for his
safe return home
yahel 15 was one of several thousand
students who was accepted into an elite
boarding school in hia and she's
interested in math and biology and hopes
to become a doctor Shea 13 loves skating
and participates in National
competitions and the last one iy 11 is a
good student has a wonderful sense of
humor and is a competitive
swimmer my
grandchildren have their whole future in
front of
them and it breaks my heart to see them
growing up in
War I hoped and I believe I did believe
that I had paid the price
and yet my
grandchildren must fight to defend their
right to life in a Jewish
State
unfortunately as I stand here before you
I have left my country in the wake of
violence murder
rape and
Terror after more than 100
days there's still
136 kidnapped
hostages dead or
alive in the hands of the
terrorists
friends I ask for your solidarity
and your
support to see those
hostages
reunited with their
families the entire country yearns to
have them back
alive help bring them back
alive
sadly after October 7 the Resurgence of
anti-Semitism means that the hate of the
past is still with
us Jews are again not feeling safe
living in
Europe after the
Holocaust this should be
unacceptable never
again should truly mean never
[Applause]
again I am
now 8 6 years
old when I was
born
Europe was still a collection of states
with major grievances against each
other Europe was able in the meantime to
set aside old hatred and come
together I truly believe that the values
that inspired the European
Unity respect for
diversity respect for freedom of
religion and the ability to live
together in
peace have an important role to play in
the future of the Middle
East I have a
dream in my dream my children all
children live in a peaceful Middle East
one that is free of hate especially
towards us the
Jews in my
dream the Jews find Safety and
Security anywhere anywhere they choose
to call
home and
anti-semitism
is finally a thing of the
past I won against
Hitler I am finally
home but my
grandchildren must now fight for its
survival I call up on
you the parliament of
Europe to
help my
dream come
true together together only together
with
you we can end
anti-Semitism and achieve a lasting
peace thank you Gra
than thank you thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
thank
you thank
you thank you I ask you colleagues thank
you thank you Irene I ask you colleagues
now to join me as we do stay standing
for a minute of
Silence
for
thank you and now for the final part of
the sermon I invite Miss Cheval and Mr
Marcelo nissman to close our cermony
with the kadish by moris
Rael
for
[Music]
the all
the
behold
[Music]
for they
are PE
my
[Music]
God
Amen
[Music]
wa
father
[Music]
the
[Applause]
[Music]
fore
the
[Music]
me
they
[Music]
ohen
thank you very much the session of the
European Parliament is adjourned and the
sitting is closed have a good
afternoon